et avec nous sur ce plateau eric
straumann comment allez-vous fin revient
ravis de vous accueillir président du
conseil départemental du haut-rhin à vos
côtés a grillé un en grande forme adrien
très grande forme aujourd'hui
alors on est ravi que vous soyez avec
nous on va partir ouf
alors aujourd'hui nous avons suivi le
haut-rhin tour des élus départementaux
et contrairement à ce que son nom
pourrait laisser entendre
il ne s'agit pas d'une épreuve sportive
quoique cette journée de travail et puis
ressembler à un véritable marathon
onze sites départementaux visité plus de
200 kilomètres parcourus à travers le
département
nous étions sur la route avec les élus
toute la matinée et ils n'ont pas chômé
regardez rendez vous donné au pied du
conseil départemental
il est 8h au programme de la journée
visite de citer le projet départementaux
un objectif familiariser l'ensemble des
élus avec les dossiers qui animeront le
conseil départemental dans les prochains
mois premier arrêt le centre culturel
europe à colmar au pied de ce bâtiment
financé par le conseil départemental
on parle politique de la ville car à
colmar comme dans d'autres villes haut
rhinoise le département s'engage le
département s'engage la politique dans
de la ville parce que la solidarité est
l'une des compétences les plus
importantes du conseil départemental le
département en fait le partenaire
principal de la ville de colmar dans
l'ensemble des travaux de rénovation qui
ont été opérés depuis près de vingt ans
maintenant dans ce quartier europe
témoignage de l'histoire qui unit les
alsace et le japon l'ancien lycée seijo
abrite maintenant le centre européen
d'études japonaises d'alsace à
kientzheim
c'est une amitié à l'autre bout du monde
que l'on cultive chaque jour il faut
continuer à entretenir ses relations
c'est vrai qu'il ya une période où les
relations
notamment la présence économique du
japon sur le territoire c'est un petit
peu comment dire un peu affaibli un
avait là avec de la directrice et le
président andré klein
on est par exemple relation avec deux
entreprises qui ont des projets sur
notre territoire en alsace on essaie
voilà de faire en sorte que de nouveaux
équipements que des extensions
d'entreprises existantes pas se réalise
ici en alsace eux plutôt que sur
d'autres pays à bergheim
on aborde un autre volet des politiques
départementales l'aide aux personnes
âgées
c'est dans ce cadre que le conseil
départemental à subventionner la
construction de l'ehpad les fraxinelle
sur ce site là donc c'est plus de deux
millions cinq cent mille euros qui ont
été consacrés donc à l'investissement
nous avons eu la chance d'avoir un
soutien aussi de l' agence régionale de
la santé sachant aussi que le
département intervient ensuite dans le
cas des aides aux personnes qui n'ont
pas les moyens ou qui n'ont plus les
moyens de le payer donc les frais
d'hébergement
enfin dernier arrêt de la matinée le
collège robert schuman à saint-amarin
après plus de 50 ans de bons et loyaux
services les bâtiments du collège
devrait faire peau neuve pour accueillir
de nouvelles générations de saint
amarinois on a été à deux collèges sur
le canton de cerner les trois autres
collèges ont fait l'objet de travaux
relativement récent leur fonctionnement
est à présent correct je pense qu'il est
absolument nécessaire maintenant de
travailler sur ce collège de
saint-amarin qui qui n'est absolument
plus aux normes et cette proximité du
collège dans ce bassin de vie est
importante même quatorze communes qui
sont dépendantes de ce collège pour nous
ce voyage s'arrête ici
mais après avoir partagé l'ordinaire des
collégiens les élus reprendront la route
direction le sud du département
voilà sacré marathon vous avez filmé la
adrien en suivant les élus ça va ça va
ça vient peu fatigué mais c'est au
président qu'il faut demander vous êtes
passé une journée marathon pourquoi
est-ce que vous avez souhaité eric
straumann emmener les élus sur le
terrain
tout simplement parce que d'assembler
très largement renouvelée on se retrouve
avec deux tiers de nouveaux conseillers
départementaux qu'il connaissait pas
tous les sites départementaux et même
moi même dans sept jours lors de cette
journée jeux découverte de nouveaux
sites
donc je connaissais l'existence sur le
papier mais que j'ai vu physiquement et
je crois que c'était intéressant pour
tout le monde en même temps dans le bus
on a un échange entre nous mais aussi
avec les services qui travaillent dans
les différents dans les différents
domaines d'activités du département
justement vous avez passé la journée
dans le concret sur le terrain
concrètement quelles vont être les
grands projets les gros chantiers de
cette rentrée alors le grand chantier de
l'art entier de la rentrée c'est la
question budgétaire
c'est vraiment le travail qu'on réalise
actuellement avec tous mes
vice-présidents et en particulier la
vice-présidente des finances on sait
qu'on a une baisse de dotation de 14
millions d'euros 1 dans le
fonctionnement et on sait aussi qu'on va
certainement avoir une augmentation des
dépenses sociales aux alentours de 16
millions de roses qui veut dire qu'il
faut qu'on trouve encore 30 millions
d'économies supplémentaires d'économies
de fonctionnement
nous y travaillons et on est en train de
conclure et de finaliser ce nouveau
budget et l'avenir quoi 30 millions
d'économies de fonctionnement
ça veut dire quoi alors comme l'a dit
mon collègue à strasbourg bieri
récemment la difficulté des départements
contrairement aux communes
ce n'est pas de buffle de réaliser des
investissements et c'est de boucler le
budget de fonctionnement c'est ça la
difficulté ribéry sur ce plateau a dit
que le bar a été quasiment en faillite
alors l'addition
on est dans une situation difficile il
faut ajuster les dépenses par rapport
aux recettes on est en faillite
lorsqu'on n'arrive pas à tenir ses
engagements
je pense que le bas-rhin arrivera à
tenir ses engagements que nous notamment
l'égard des collectivités locales on a
souhaité me respecter les contrats de
territoire de vie et tous les
engagements qui ont été signés c'est
quelque chose qu'on n'a pas pu voir dans
le reportage parce que c'était cet après
midi vous vous êtes rendus à huningue
donc vous avez évoqué le quartier dry
land la question de l'euroairport la
coopération avec nos voisins c'est
quelque chose de fondamental
l'euroairport et tout le secteur de
l'euroairport
ça va être un peu le développement
essentiel pour le département du haut
rhin
c'est un aéroport qui va représenter
certainement pour la région grand est le
premier aéroport en terme de
fréquentation
on va atteindre c1 le niveau de deux
nombres de passagers aux alentours de 7
5 millions de passagers au cours de
cette année voire 8 millions et
probablement si on a une proto sur la d
re sur l'a10 prospective un peu réaliste
on sait qu'on va atteindre 10 millions
de ps2 passagers d'ici d'ici deux ans
donc ça va être une source de
développement considérable pour nos
départements alors il ya toute cette
activité aérienne
à tout ce qui tourne autour nous avons
notamment avec la communauté de communes
sur place un projet de mme hall 1 c'est
là projet unibail avec à l'apport de
l'aéroport un grand centre commercial
avec des cinémas avec également une
connexion à partir ces territoires ce
qui serait sur le territoire
essentiellement c'est bon enfin en fait
il ne serait qu'en france parce que on
les suisses n'ont plus beaucoup d espace
pour se développer et donc ils regardent
également vers verdun l'alsace pour
trouver de l'espace pour développer
leurs activités
donc ce que disait adrien la raison
c'est que c'est un des dossiers clés
pour vous la coopération
transfrontalière sur têt donc
certainement et le secteur de hull 1 va
être la californie haut rhinoise au
cours des prochaines années on le sent
bien il y à un développement économique
tout à fait considérable du côté de bâle
avec des embauches à la clé on a un taux
de chômage aux alentours de 3 4% dans le
secteur de de huningue et c'est vraiment
un secteur qu'il faut soutenir
encourager et ça va être la clé quelque
part de notre avenir économique
départemental même si nous perdons la
compétence économique à partir de l'an
prochain puisque vous le savez c'est la
région qui va récupérer théoriquement et
piloter l'économie avec les structures
intercommunales
mais là encore avec avec mon collègue du
bas rhin on souhaite que les
départements restent présents à travers
des agences de développement économique
qui conserveront si vous voulez leur
périmètre actuel et qui permettront
aussi aux conseils départementaux d'être
présents sur leur territoire notamment à
côté des chefs d'entreprises trop mal de
questions d'actualité la première
ségolène royal était en visite
aujourd'hui à strasbourg à l'annoncé la
fermeture de la centrale de fessenheim
pour 2018 bonne ou mauvaise chose
alors je sais pas s'il s'agit d'un couac
de toute façon pour les connaisseurs du
dossier on savait que 2017 n'était pas
une échéance de nabeul pour des raisons
techniques pour des raisons juridiques
bon 'l'annonce 2018 je sais pas si le
premier ministre ehoud présent d'un
public était au courant de cette de
cette annonce
la centrale ne fermera pas en 2017 elle
ne fermerait pas non plus en 2018
alors ce qui aidera aussi étonnant sur
le fond puisque c'est elle et et
initiatrice de la loi sur la transition
énergétique
ce n'est pas le gouvernement qui décide
de quelle centrale va fermer c'est edf
qui choisit la centrale où l'étrange
quatre souhaitent arrêter en fonction
des objectifs qui ont été fixés par le
législateur
parce que si demain évidemment le
gouvernement on peut décider de la
fourniture d'une centrale
mais dans ce cas il faudra indemniser
edf l'exploitant mais ça représente
plusieurs millions milliard d'euros
d'indemnités à verser
je sais pas si c'est réfléchi si ça
s'est fait sur un coup de tête il
s'éteint quoique bon si c'est un quoique
ça ne m'étonnerait pas mais de toute
façon
l'échéance de 17 n'est pas possible de
tenir on peut pas tenir cette échéance
de 2010 en tout cas à suivre autre
actualité ce sera l'an prochain vous
devrez abandonné un mandat c'est la loi
sur le non-cumul
est-ce que vous avez déjà une idée de ce
que vous lâcherez s'écouter on verra le
moment venu il faisait déjà partie en se
séparant prochain d'ailleurs c'est en
2017 2017
2010 est donc on verra d'ici là comment
les choses vont évoluer comment la
grande région va fonctionner comment
vous êtes pour comment comment comment
commandant du comment le bar comment le
parlement va fonctionner
quel sera le président de la république
qui va être élu quelles sont les
conditions du fonctionnement de ce
nouveau modèle démocratique qui va
certainement apparaître les va partir et
le deuxième à saint jude je vous donne
quelques sentiments est ce que
finalement il n'y a pas plus de poids
quand on a comme vous président du
conseil départemental et qu'on ait
entendu à paris j'avais posé cette
question à roland ries ce qui était
plutôt dans cette veine là de dire on
peut faire rayonner à paris un
territoire quel est votre avis alors
c'est quand même objectivement plus
difficile pour un élu local
qui n'a pas d'implantation parisienne
pour se faire connaître parce qu'on
pascal trois quatre jours on met sur les
bancs avec les ministres ont on est avec
des collègues parlementaires et je le
vois pratique aussi lorsque j'envoie un
courrier avec l'en-tête conseil général
j'ai une réponse moins rapide lorsque je
que lorsque je le mets sur en tête
assemblée nationale et que sa part de
paris 1 et donc j'ai un double
imprimantes si vous voulez et temps en
temps même pour les intérêts
départementaux et bien j'utilise le
courrier assemblée nationale parce qu'il
a n'a pas complètement différent à paris
qu'un courrier à 100 claque houllier du
conseil départemental
il en est ainsi la france est organisée
d'une manière très centralisé c'est
malheureux mais c'est par exemple vous
voulez changer un panneau sur une
autoroute alsacienne bien il faut savoir
que la décision se prend quasiment à
paris enfin je l' ai vécu la décision se
prend à paris et il ya beaucoup de
points de détails comme ça qui sont
réglés malheureusement dans la sphère
parisienne les choses pourront peut-être
évoluer mais je ne croit d'ailleurs pas
que la grande région va donner une
réponse assez à ces problématiques